[Music]
so this is actually my first time in
Japan and I cannot speak Japanese so
this is going to be a trip where I'll
use generative AI maybe Gemini and chbt
to help me travel in Japan so let's see
how it's going to
[Music]
be because I'm traveling and I usually
need Maps so I chose to use Google's
Gemini because it has an integration
with Google Map because I use iPhone
I'll go to App Store type in Google and
then I select this app the Google app
once you have downloaded to your iPhone
tap to open it and you will see two tabs
the search Tab and the Gemini tab now in
the Gemini tab you can tab the input box
and start typing your
question first you can ask J about the
general information of the place that
you are going like manners of the people
culture or areas to
avoid so I asked about Japanese manners
well it told me to be mindful of my
noise level in the public but what
surprised me is that it told me to be on
the left side of the escalator which is
opposite to my
culture now I am going to ask about
areas I should
avoid yeah Tokyo is generally considered
a safe City but there are areas like
kabukicho rongi chinuku euko that might
be a little bit dangerous I guess that
is normal to big cities
anyway it proceed to give me general
safety tips like be aware of my
surrounding keep my valuables close to
me if I'm unsure about any anything ask
the local or ask a hotel staff well I
guess the police should be fine
too last one let's ask how to say thank
you in Japanese language it suggested me
two versions of arikoto kusas as you can
see here number two Gemini can help you
explore the area because it has an
integration with Google Map I'm going to
ask Gemini for Japanese cafes around my
hotel
[Music]
it initially get me five
recommendations and it showed them in
the map as well and I want to refine my
search to carace near the subway station
jini then refined my search and gave me
top five
recommendations it could also aggregate
pictures of these carf face for me to
take a look I then change the subject to
a Ramen Shop in the same area
so guys I just follow J the suggestion I
am here at King real coffee shop asakusa
this is the arm on guys look at
that the shop is quite small but the
cofy tastes great and the lady was
really coffee over there so I think Jim
and I Works they recommend me to come to
this place and it doesn't disappo me
number three describe an image of dot
dot this is extremely useful to me when
I'm curious about the product or the
food or the medicine that I'm buying or
I want to know what this poster is all
[Music]
about so I'm here at hji Lake in kakiko
and you can see a Fuji Mountain at the
back there um so can I conclude that
generative AI works I think it partially
Works um to travel uh in a sense that it
can help you find local information
quickly off the internet like the manner
and the culture or it can try to explain
the image for example like the product
that I showed you earlier but sometimes
it cannot really understand or it cannot
know um the local information that is
not captured well on the internet an
example is in Japan for example it might
be considered a low resource language so
the generative AI even Gemini couldn't
know the best place to take a look at
the fji mountain like this um this the
hotel that I'm staying at it's called
Shi Lake hotel um it's very difficult to
find information on the internet and
most of the time it's in Japanese
language um so yeah I got to here
because I know a friend who came here
before so my trip is actually human AI
travel don't forget to give us likes
leave your comments share us to your
friends and also subscribe to our
channels we have YouTube LinkedIn Tik
Tok and Facebook